قال نائب رئيس المجلس السياده السوداني
ملك عقار ان بلاده ترفض مبادره الاتحاد
الافريقي لحل الازمه السودانيه بسبب تعليق
عضويه السودان كما وصف عقار مبادره دول
الايجاد بانها مبادره احتلال بسبب سعيها
لادخال قوات النوليه الى السودان وجعل
منطقه الخرطوم منزوعه السلاح بحسب تعريره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كندا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى وجهه الحيثيات التي
ساقتها الخرطوم لتوضيح اسباب رفضها
مبادرتي الاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد ومرد
المنظمتين على هذه الحيثيات وكيف سيتعامل
الاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد مع قرار
السودان رفض مبادره سيهما وما الاوراق
التي يملكانها لانقاذ مبادرتيهما من الفشل
وما هي فرص حل الازمه السودانيه بعد تعثر
العديد من المبادرات بالتوازن مع استمرار
القتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع وتفاقم
الاوضاع الانسانيه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
بموازاه الاستمرار القتال بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في الخرطوم بل وخروج
المعارك الى جبهات اخرى في دارفور وجنوب
كردفان وبالتزامن مع اعلان واشنطن على
لسان مساعدتي وزير خارجيتها لشؤون
الافريقيه تعليق محادثات السلام بين
الطرفي اسرع السوداني بسبب ما سمته عدم
خروج الصيغه بالطريقه المطلوبه اكد نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني ملك عقار رفض
بلاده مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي لحل الازمه
السودانيه بسبب تعليق ارضيه السودان كما
ابدع عقار تحفظات على مبادره دول الايجاد
واشار الى انها تسعى لادخال قوات دوليه
الى السودان وجعل منطقه الخرطوم منزوعه
السلاح ما جعلها مبادره احتلال بحسب
تعبيره
كما جدد نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
رفض حكومه السودان لرئاسه كينيا للجنه
للجنه ايجاد رباعيه واتهم النيروبي بعدم
الحياد
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا عبر
الهاتف من الخرطوم الفريق اول فتح الرحمن
محي الدين قائد القوات البحريه السودانيه
سابقا وينضم الينا من ادي السبب في
اثيوبيا موسى شيخو الباحث في الشؤون
الافريقيه اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه وابدا
معك في الخرطوم الفريق فتح الرحمن طبعا
مجلس السياده كما هو معروف اعلن رفضه
مبادرتي مبادره ايجاد ومبادره الاتحاد
الافريقي بل وصف مبادره ايجاد بانها
مبادره احتلال برايك في ماذا استند في
رفضه هذا الى ماذا السند
الكريم من اثيوبيا وشكرا على الاستضافه
نحتفل انه يعني منذ ان ظهرت مبادره
الايجاد وزاره الخارجيه اصدرت في مجموعه
من التحفظات على موارده هذه المبادره وهي
ترى انهم يمكن ان تكون مدخلا للحل اذا
اخذت في الاعتبار الملاحظات التي ابدتها
بازاره الخارجيه ولكن للاسف نجد ان
الرباعيه المتمثله في كينيا واثيوبيا
وجنوب السودان
واحيانا يقولون جبتي واحيانا يقولون
تجاهلوا تماما تحفظات وزاره الخارجيه
السودانيه ومدوا بدعوى اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه لهذه الدول في كينيا ومنذ البدايه
الحكومه السودانيه اوضحت ان كينيا دوله
غير محايده في هذه الازمه كينيا بمعروف
تماما
الانتخابيه للرئيس الكيني الحالي مبلغ
خمسه مليون دولار وبالتالي الان كينيا
تستضيف عناصر من التمرد في في في كينيا
وايضا يعني تنحاز انحياز واضح جدا للتمرد
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان تكون طرفا في حل
الازمه الامر الاخر
قال في 24 مايو بانه يجب توحيد كل
المبادرات تحت مظله مبادره ايجاد كيف نفهم
هذا التناقض
البدايه لكن وزاره الخارجيه خالد مبادره
ايجاد مبادره جيده يمكن ان نقبل بها لانه
المنظمه يعني السودان له فيها دور فاعل
لكن بشرط ان لا تكون
رئاسه كينيا وان تكون
تاخذ بالاعتبار الملاحظات التي ابدتها
الخارجيه السودانيه لكن كونك تتجاهل
ملاحظات الخارجيه السودانيه
ايجاد كيف تؤثر في قرار ايجاد بهذا الشكل
المضخم
رباعيا هذه اللجنه الرباعيه
السوق بغيت لوحدها
لكن
جعل الخرطوم منطقه منزوعه السلاح هذا يعني
انك تسعى الى احتلال الكبرى الى موسى
لماذا اذا تقترح ايجاد كما كان يشرح لنا
الان الفريق الرحمن جعل منطقه الخرطوم
العاصمه السودانيه منطقه منزوعه
السلاح ولماذا دعت الى ادخال قوات اجنبيه
الى الخرطوم
نعم تحيه لك ولساده المشاهدين وبالضيف
الكريم
الوضع في السودان
وضع معقد جدا منذ اليوم الاول الجيش
السوداني تعهد بانه يحسم الامر خلال يومين
او خلال اسبوع ومره الاسبوع والاسبوعان
والشهر والشهران ولم يتم الحسم والان
السودان عامه والخرطوم خاصه في اسوا وضعها
وما تهدف اليه
منظمه الايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي هو ايقاف
الحرب
الالتفات الى الحاله الانسانيه التي
يعيشها السودانيون في الداخل وفي دول وفي
المعابر
فالايجاد كلما تريده هو ايقاف الحرب اولا
ثم معالجه الحاله الانسانيه ثم الحل
التدريجي
والاعتراض على
لا تتصرف بمفردها وانما تتصرف من خلال
الدول الايجاد ودول الايجاد يعني دول
الجوار السوداني والكل يعترف بان
الدول الجوار السوداني لهم دور اساسي في
حل المشكله السودانيه
فرفض السودان الان لكل المبادرات
ازمه مع المبعوثه الاممي نعم قد يكون هناك
مشكله مع بعث الاممي ثم رفض الاتحاد
الافريقي
كله والان المحادثات
هل هذا موقف كل دول ايجاد
لا الايجاد هي يعني من خلال الاليه
الرباعيه من كينيا هي دوله لا تتصرف
بمفردها فاذا كانت كينيا يعني لم تكن
محايده اذا تصرفت بمفردها فليس من المعقول
ان تتركها
فهذه الدول عفوا اذا ما خلف ما هي فلسفتها
في طرح هذه الاقتراحات اذا
هي مبادره هي في منظمه الايجاد يهمها كلما
يهم
الدول منظمه الايجاد
كينيا ليست لوحدها فقط كل دول الجوار
السوداني بما التي في الايجاد والتي في
غير الايجاد كلهم تقدموا بمبادرات
والاتحاد الافريقي قال
تحدث عن خارطه الطريق حتى لا تتجاذب هذه
المبادرات
وتتاثر بتقاطع المصالح لهذه الدول
جمع الجميع تحت ما يسمى بمجموعه الاتصال
الدوليه حتى تحوي كل المبادرات بما فيها
اعلان جده فاستنادا على هذا
منظمه الايجاد تقدمت باليه قالت انه يكون
حل
فالاخوه في السودان سواء الدعم السري
والجيش السوداني كلهم كانوا جزء من المكون
العسكري السوداني والان
لم يقدر احد ان يحسم الوضع
فالان الحرب تندلع في كل مكان
والفصائل الحركات المسلحه منهم من بدا
الان في في كردفان وباقي فصائل الحركات
المسلحه لا تتحمل كثيرا يعني نحن امام
انهيار السودان وما تقوله الايجاد هو منع
لهذا
انهيار سحب الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع وفريق فتح الرحمن يعني يقول
موسى الشيخ نحن امام حاله انهيار للسودان
ولدوله السودانيه
سيد مالك عقار والبرهان ما زالوا يصرون
رغم كل ذلك على توصيف ما يجري على يعني
انه
ليس حرب بين دوله وعفوا ليس حرب بين طرفين
ولكن بين دوله ومتمردين ورغم ذلك لم
يستطيعوا اقناع احد بهذا التوصيف العالم
لم يقتنع بهذا التفصيل توصيف لماذا فشلوا
في اقناع العالم بهذا التوصيف الذي ما
زالوا يصرون عليه حتى اليوم
نعم لما انا اعتقد انه العالم لا يريد ان
يرى الحقيقه العالم لا يريد ان يصنف
الازمه تصنيفا صحيحا حتى هذه المبادره
مبادره لايجاد تصنف الازمه بانها الازمه
بين جنرين واجمع على السلطه وهذا هو توصيف
خاطي وبالتالي اي توصيف خاطي لا يمكن ان
يوصلنا الى حل الازمه التوصيف الصحيح انه
هذه الازمه هي ازمه
فصيل متمرد على الامه السودانيه وليست
القوات المسلحه السودانيه المسلحه
السودانيه تغاتل نيابه عن الشعب السوداني
لكن كل الشعب السوداني
فقط على حق يعني العالم لماذا لم يقتنع
هذا التوصيف
يا عزيزتي لان العالم لا يريد ان يقتنع
لكن هنالك الاف الفيديوهات التي استثبت
على ان هذه الحركه المتمرده حركه ارهابيه
وممارسه كل انواع الارهاب من قتل واختصاب
والسلب والنف كل ممارسات الارهاب التي
شاهدناها في بوكو حرام التي شاهدناها في
تنظيم داعش مارستها هذه المتمرده من
شاهدناه في انحاء العالم الاخر ايضا
العالم لا يريد ان صفات الشعب السوداني
خلف قواته المسلحه في كل ولايات السودان
اذا انت كل مره معلش فريق فريق فتح الرحمن
انت في كل مره تطلع معنا على شاشه الجزيره
وعلى وسائل الاعلام تقول الجيش على وشك
الحسم كم منطقه مع حجم المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها الجيش في الخرطوم لو سمحتي فقط اقول
لك ان اذا كنا نتحدث
السريع الذي نعرفه
في هذا
الصناعه المتمرد اتت الينا من غرب افريقيا
نصارع الدول
تسميه هذه الدول هذه
السريع الذي كنا نعرف الاسبوع الاول
كل معسكرات من الاسبوع الاول والان نحارب
نطاقا اقليميا
يضخ الاف عشرات الالاف من المتمردين من
السويق الوسطى
من شهر مالي ومن ليبيا هؤلاء كلهم الان
يتدفقون نحو الخرطوم ولكنها ستكون مقبرتهم
جميعا ان شاء الله
حتى السوداني يجب ان يفهم الجميع عند
السودان ليست الخرطوم معظم ولايه السودان
مستقره تماما فيها طبيعيه هذا بعض مدن في
دارفورد باستثناء غرب دارفور بعض المدن
تمت فيها مهاجمات للقوات المسلحه وتم دحر
التمرد من اول نصف ساعه في هذه المناطق
ولا يوجد مقنع بالنسبه لكم ولماذا الاسراء
نعم ساعود اليك ساعود اليك ساعود اليك
فريق فتح الله موسى شيخو الى اي مدى يعني
كلام الفريق فتح الله فتح الرحمن مقنع
بالنسبه لاي مراقب لاي متابع ولماذا
الاصرار كان طرح قبل قبل في بدايه
البرنامج
مغزى الاصرار على على كينيا على
اسناد رئاسه الاليه المصغره للايجاد
لكينيا رغم رفض الخرطوم لرئاسه كينيا لهذه
الاليه
اولا الاصرار على رئاسه كينيا يعني ليس
اصرارا على كينيا وانما اصرارا على الاليه
الاليه الرباعيه
فكينيا مجرد واجهه لمنظمه الايجاد الثاني
لماذا لا يقتنع العالم بان ما يحضر ما
يحدث في الخرطوم هو التمرد لان الحكومه
السودانيه الموجوده الان
هي حكومه انقلاب
جاءت بعد ابعاد حكومه مدنيه
فالدعم السريع كان جزءا من هذه الدوله
لا يوجد صديق اقرب لحميده من البرهان
اين كان اين كانت جهاز المخابرات
السودانيه واين كان
المخابرات الحربيه السودانيه حينما يدخل
كل هذا السلاح بما فيها مضاد الطائرات الى
العاصمه الخرطوم اذا
العالم كله يقتنع بان ما يحدث في السودان
هو تقاتل على السلطه وبان
الخلاف هو خلاف بين جنرين وانا شخصيا
اتمنى ان
الجيش السوداني هو المنتصر وان القوات
المسلحه السودانيه ان تنتصر لكن في
الحقيقه الانتصار الان كما نراقبه من ان
كثب بعيد المنال لا احد يحسم وانما القادم
هو انهيار السودان اذا لم يتعقل القادم
متقاتلات نعم ونحاول ان نستشرف المستقبل
وما الخطوات القادمه ولكن ذكرت نقطه الان
اريد ان احولها الى الفريق فتح فتح الرحمن
وهي ما كنا قد ناقشناه في سابقا وهو انه
لماذا العالم لم يقتنع قال لك موسى شيخ
العالم لا يمكن ان يقتنع بذلك وان ما يجري
هو عباره عن تقاتل على السلطه بين جنرال
لان ما يحدث هو عباره عن يعني افرازات
انقلاب على
الثوره وعلى مخرجاتها كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام
اولا اجراءات 25 اكتوبر 21 لم تكن انقلاب
25 اكتوبر كانت تصحيح لمسار الثوره كان
هنالك انسداد في الافق السياسي كان هنالك
مهددات امنيه خطيره كانت ستحصل في البلاد
وبالتالي كان لابد لغات المسلحه تتدخل
وتصحح مسار الثوره وصحيحه اعتبرها انقلاب
وعلق عضويه السودان منذ ذلك التاريخ ولكن
حتى كان جزءا من هذا التصحيح للثوره ولكن
بعد ذلك في العام 22 عندما اتى الينا
فولكر
بصيغه المحامين التي اتت من خارج السودان
ولكي تفرض على الشعب السوداني ثم بعد ذلك
الاتفاق الايطاليه يعني معلش لا فلكر
عجبكم للمبعوث
المباط الامم المتحده
ترفضونه او ترفضه الحكومه ويرفضه البرهان
والجيش ولا مبادره ايجاد ولا مبادره
الاتحاد الافريقي مما الصيغه الذي ترضي
اذا الحكومه
يفكك السودان وجندته كانت واضحه ومنذ
البدايه غنه اذا كنا نريد حل للازمه يجب
ان نبعد هذا الفولكر من السودان الان
السودان
نعم معقول انه العالم كله يتامر عليكم
[موسيقى]
لماذا لا يريدون ان احترموا سيادتنا لماذا
لا يريدون
ان نحقق امننا باستقرارنا وتنميتنا
بانفسنا
ما الاوراق نعم الفكره واضحه
الاوراق الافريقيه الممكنه لحلحله وضع
معقد او شديد التعقيد بهذا الشكل
السؤال نعم نعم موسى شيخو
سيد موسى نعم
الحل الافريقي واضح نعم الحل الافريقي
واضح وهو سحب الجهات المتقاتله من العاصمه
الخرطوم واحلال الشرطه السودانيه محلها
بمراقبه قوات من دول الايجاد وليس قوه
حتى يستطيع الناس
نعم ولكن هذا الحل رفض
هذا الحل لم يعني رفض من من مكون عسكري
وليس من السودانيين السودان لا يعني
البرهان ولا يعني حميدتي السودان في احزاب
سودانيه في في تيارات في منظمات في الشعب
السوداني يعني كيف يمكن فرضه
ما هل من اليات لفرضه اذا كيف سيفرض على
من يرفضه
لا يمكن لا يمكن فرضه لكن على السودانيين
ان يتعقلوا التصادم في هذا الوقت مع كل
الجهات سواء الافريقيه وسواء الامميه
الاقليميه هذا ليس من المعقول نظريه
المؤامره هي التي اهلكت كثيرا من الاوطان
في افريقيا والعالم العربي
بعض الجهات في الحكومه السودانيه الموجوده
الان ينظرون الى الامور من نظريه
المؤامره كينيا لا تستطيع ان تتصرف لوحدها
فالاتحاد الافريقي حينما علق عضويه
السودان لا يعني بذلك السودان فقط هذا
الدستور في الاتحاد الافريقي تعليق اي
دوله
يعني ليس فيها دستور ولا برلمان يتم ابعاد
حكومه مدنيه متخصصه فهذا هي المشكله
الخيارات هو ان
ينصاع السودانيون
ليلتفتوا للازمه الانسانيه
فيتحاوروا يعني هذا مش في وقت حرب
البيانات وتصلح
اذا كان 67 يوم والان اعود الى الفريق فتح
الرحمن سبعه وستون يوما والحرب تتسع
والازمه الانسانيه تتفاقم والحل يبدو
بعيدا كيف ترى المستقبل ما هي البدائل
الممكنه
اولا اذا اثرت الايجاد على هذا
الحفل يستطيع ان ينسحب من عضيه الايجاز
كليه وتروح الاجابات في 60 الف داهيه اذا
كان اذا كنا نتحدث عن 67 يوم من القتال
صحيح هنالك يعني خسرنا كثيرا جدا في
البنيه التحتيه في مواردنا في شبابنا في
كثير من الدماء التي سالت في ترويع
المواطنين في تهجير المواطنين ولكن ما
سندفعه من استمرار الحرب الذي يكون اغلى
مما
هو الحجم العسكري هو الذي تمضي فيه القوات
المسلحه
العسكري الحسم العسكري قادم على شاشه
الجزيره
عزيزه في القوات المسلحه تقبل باكثر من 12
هدنه هذا كله تقبيل للقوات المسلحه واعاده
عذرا لمقاطعتك لان الوقت وقت البرنامج
انتهى شكرا جزيلا لك الفريق اول فتح
الرحمن محي الدين قائد القوات البحريه
السودانيه سابقا كنت معنا من الخرطوم ومن
اديس ابا موسى شيخو الباحث في الشؤون
الافريقيه كنت معنا من اثيوبيا شكرا لكما
وبهذا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]